voilà ce qu'on appelle un bain de foule
un vrai après l'assermentation et la
conférence de presse contraste frappant
avec son prédécesseur
justin trudeau s'approchent de ceux qui
ont attendu des heures pour le voir et
pour le touché et oui bien sûr pour
prendre la photo souvenir qui se
retrouvera sur facebook ou twitter
sanaa a beau brad go un casse tête pour
la sécurité sans doute mais le public et
même les bébés sont de la fête
quel privilège de pouvoir être ici pour
être témoins de l'événement canadian le
gouverneur général avait envoyé
l'invitation à tous question peut-être
de marquer un changement de ton une
ouverture qu'on n'avait pas vu à ottawa
en neuf ans finies les années un peu
nous dit ce spectateur des années
marquées par la peur et le stylite et
quelques 3000 personnes se sont
rassemblées à ried oral pour suivre la
cérémonie d'assermentation sur écran
géant
boire du chocolat chaud et marquait le
début de ce qu'elle appelle une nouvelle
ère en minuk sont assez vieux pour se
souvenir de l'époque où le cabinet
compte est une femme
chirac apps la parité hommes femmes au
cabinet à diversité ethnique un cabinet
qui ressemble un canada multiculturel
cet homme a immigré au canada sous
pierre elliott dit il il vient
aujourd'hui rendre hommage au fils des
moments de joie et des moments de grande
émotion
résumé les parents du nouveau ministre
de la famille jean yves duclos ont suivi
la servante ation de leur fils dehors de
votre heureux très fier et dans la foule
on retrouve même des nostalgiques comme
cette femme qui est venue avec sa robe
pierre elliott trudeau des années 60
entre soleil cote d'amour et bonne
humeur 1
mélange idéal il on est loin très loin
de la réalité de la vie politique
elle commencera sous peu aujourd'hui
c'est encore la lune de miel ici joyce
n'ai pu radio canada ottawa